marina ramírez es desempleada y madre
soltera la falta de recursos le ha
llevado a valerse de ayudas sociales
como la olla común para alimentar a sus
cuatro hijos y más que todo porque todo
está caro y porque no alcanza porque a
veces no hay trabajo todo ha subido toda
su vida y no hay trabajo por las
circustancias del gobierno y lo que está
mal en lo que vivimos en perú más de 8
millones de personas viven en situación
de pobreza y más de un millón son pobres
extremos según el instituto nacional de
estadística-
4000 ollas comunes creadas por mujeres
son el único paliativo que tienen los
más necesitados para alimentarse en
estos momentos sin embargo están en
riesgo de cerrar porque no reciben
recursos ante la crisis el gobierno
evalúa entregar un bono de más de 324
millones de dólares medida que es
criticada por diversos economistas lo
que debería hacer el gobierno más bien
es ayudar a las ollas comunes a
abastecer con productos a las ollas
comunes cosas que hasta el momento no ha
hecho o sea olímpicamente hay 2600 hoy
comunes que están
abandonadas que no tienen atención
sistemática por parte del gobierno
porfa esteban vive un doble drama además
de batallar para que la olla común que
dirige no cierre por falta de alimentos
también tiene que luchar por sanar a su
hijo que forma parte del 38% de los
niños peruanos que sufren de anemia me
siento triste por lo que mi niño me está
así bajo peso y allí están bien igual
que están igual bueno y son más más
chiquitos también me voy a común así
como marina y orf a otros 15 millones de
peruanos no pueden comer tres veces al
día también un 11.5 por ciento de niñas
y niños menores de 5 años están en
situación de desnutrición crónica
pero no se escapa la crisis alimentaria
mundial que ya está afectando a toda
latinoamérica